today on the matt walsh show a woman
called internal affairs to complain that
an la county sheriff's deputy harassed
her during a traffic stop but body cam
footage
which has been released shows a
completely different story also five
headlines including
outrage at rick santorum for claiming
that europeans built our civilization
but isn't that simply an indisputable
historical fact
and caitlyn jenner comes out against men
playing in women's sports but does that
mean we can trust him
as conservatives plus the gates are
getting divorced and our daily
cancellation the disney classic snow
white and the seven dwarves
is finally being called out for its
promotion of rape culture
it's about time all of that and more
today on the matte wall show
you know this last year has taught us
anything it's that uh emergencies
happen you never know what's going to
happen exactly but you have to be
prepared for anything
and that's where ready wise comes in
i've been telling you about ready wise
for a long time
and now is a better time than any to be
prepared with long-term nutritional food
options
ready wise has many options like
emergency meals freeze dried fruits and
vegetables for convenient on the go to
nutrition they also have adventure meals
for hiking camping
and other outdoor activities are really
convenient and also they taste great
ready wise makes being prepared simple
and affordable you can order online
and have nutritious meals shipped
directly to your doorstep when
government resources are strained
it can be days if not weeks before fresh
food is available to you
you want to put yourself in a position
where you're relying on the government
at a time like that
ready wise uses the finest ingredient
and ingredients in latest food
preparation technology to ensure optimal
taste
and freshness so you've got to take
advantage of this and here's the deal
this week my listeners
can get 10 percent off at readywise.com
when entering walsh at checkout or by
calling
855 475-3089 freddy weiss is a 30-day no
questions asked return policy
so there's no risk in taking the
initiative to get you and your family
prepared today that's readywise
r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e dot com promo code
walsh to get 10
off the correspondent for fox news bill
mulligan
uh published a video on monday that
helps put things into perspective
this is what life is like for police
officers these days the video is footage
from a body camera
worn by a los angeles county sheriff's
deputy interestingly enough
the department doesn't require its
officers to wear body cameras this
officer
chose to wear one for his own protection
and it's very good
that he made that choice because
recently a woman called internal affairs
to file a harassment complaint against
him she claimed
that he harassed her during a traffic
stop unfortunately the deputy had his
camera rolling during that stop
and it becomes very clear very quickly
just who is doing the harassing during
this interaction
the woman is so far unnamed and as soon
as she is named i'll be sure to tell you
her name and
plaster it everywhere that i can now i'm
not always a fan of public shaming but
some people richly deserve it and oh
does this woman
deserve it uh so let's uh let's play
this let's listen to this
i was going at 38. yes you are ma'am
good morning which is and the speed
limit is 40
and i was going 38 so why are you
harassing you are correct
i pulled you over because you're a
murderer yes i started to record because
you can't beat it
you can't be on your cell phone while
you're driving when i was recording you
because you see you can't you can't use
your cell phone while you're recording
you
may have your driver's license i it's
it's at my
apartment what's your apartment it's at
my home i'm just taking my son to his
do you have do you have your driver's
license it i mistakenly left it at home
do you have a picture of your driver's
license yes i do may have it
and can you call your supervisor please
i already did he's on his way
because you're a murderer okay
and so you're giving me a cell phone
ticket is that why you're harassing me
not harassment i i am enforcing the law
i have a right to
and record the police when they're
harassing me by all means
but you can't do it while you're driving
i was i can i wasn't
doesn't texting or none of that do you
have you had that picture
of me and made me think you were going
to murder me okay well i'm sorry you
feel that way well you're that's not
just a feeling you're a murderer
okay can you zoom in on that for me yeah
thank you and i'm
perfectly legal and i'm a teacher
so there congratulations of course she
is
of course she's a teacher oh you knew
that you just
from this from everything her behavior
the sound of her voice
you already knew she was a teacher
melligan says that she
has worked as a professor at colleges in
the area apparently this is just another
reason why her name and faith should be
published
the public has the right to know where
this psycho is teaching
besides she was filming the encounter
too so she obviously wants it to be made
public
i mean we should respect her wishes and
make it as public as possible she wants
to be famous so i say let's oblige
there's plenty more to say about this
and a couple of larger points i want to
make but first let's uh let's watch the
rest of the footage because it does gets
worse
it does get worse if you can believe it
you're a murderer
what's your last name i can't see that
there well here stop shaking
zoom in on that phone because you're
scaring me they're threatening to kill
me and my son
can you give me okay you don't tell you
what you keep smiling you're on camera
you're you're trying to threaten to kill
me i've been smiling you're the one
who's
hold that still i can't see that is this
your car yes it is
and you're trying to say i stole my own
car because you're jealous
yeah i don't think so you away from me
right here okay
you're jealous you've got the citation
all you need to do is your signature
he's only citing you for using your cell
phone while you're driving that's it
there you go
sign inside the river for him being a
mexican racist
what is that name yes it's on the
citation man here you go mexican racist
you're always going to be a mexican
you'll never be white you know that
right
you'll never be white which is what you
really want to be there you go dear
right
have a good day you want to be white so
bad
what a lovely what a lovely woman a
little racism there at the end why not
why not throw that in there for good
measure
you've already decided to be a scumbag
might as well go full hog i guess
and yet after all that the vile
disgusting
witch of a woman gets only a citation
for using a cell phone while driving
the officer actually cuts her a break
doesn't get her for driving without a
license
needless to say this is a man with with
mere super human patience
if that were me i would have given her
every ticket i could have possibly
justified and then a few more that i
can't
i also probably would have been
screaming at her to shut her stupid
mouth
because you know i'm on the opposite end
of the patient spectrum i have to admit
this is the kind of patience that police
officers must
so often demonstrate they deal with
people like this
all the time in fact that was easy
compared to how so many other traffic
stops have gone
especially in la at least she didn't
physically assault the officer or try to
shoot him so that's progress
privacy can lend a little bit of
perspective some police officers
are bad just like some members of every
profession are bad in some professions
the percentage of bad
is much higher than others professions
like academia for example
riddled with lunatics like this for
police officers only some are bad
some like this deputy are almost
unbelievably good at their jobs
everyone else falls in between they're
just normal people doing their best
bad days and good days successes and
failures getting by as well they can
i mean this describes the vast majority
of people on earth
in all vocations and all occupations
now what happens when a normal person
is subjected to constant harassment and
taunting
what happens when they're forced to
encounter the absolute dregs of humanity
day in and day out what happens when
they spend all day
every day dealing with drug addicts
domestic abusers
gang bangers drunks people of that sort
it has a psychological effect so my
point is that whenever we see
body cam footage of some citizen
acting like a lunatic around the police
we're always
asked to see things from that person's
perspective to understand the pain and
trauma that led to that behavior and so
on
what about the pain and trauma of the
guy wearing the camera
might we consider things from his
perspective too sometimes
i know that if i had to deal with people
like that woman every day and worse
it wouldn't take long to turn me into a
jaded aggressive jerk
in fact i already am a jaded aggressive
jerk and i only work in media
so the majority of police critics
if they had to deal with stuff like that
all the time
they'd be far worse than the worst
police officer that they criticized
two other things to think about first we
don't talk enough about the entitlement
problem
and how it intersects with these issues
this woman
has a sense of entitlement so pronounced
that it's driven her
into basically madness
she's furious that the officer would
dare pull her over to enforce the law
she feels that she's entitled to do
whatever she wants
whenever she wants and anybody who danes
to prevent her is to her mind
effectively a murderer
she's so entitled that even when the
officer cuts her a massive break
she still isn't satisfied to have even
been inconvenienced is an affront that
she cannot bear
now she might be a somewhat extreme case
but this kind of entitlement
to one degree or another is
extraordinarily common
it's another thing that cops run into
every single day just consider the fact
that in a great many of the police body
cam videos or witness cell phone videos
we've seen
the perp who was allegedly the victim of
police brutality was committing a crime
and then resisted arrest when the police
came to enforce the law
they act shocked and angered by the fact
that the law is being applied
to them they're so self-entitled that
they expect they can
refuse to be arrested and the cop will
just go well okay never mind sir
sorry to have sorry to have bothered you
in this fine afternoon
when the cop doesn't respond that way
they become violent
again police encounter this mentality
day in and day out
also the woman in that video let's focus
on this for a second
she repeatedly claims that she is scared
another thing we hear all the time all
these people who say they're scared to
death afraid they'll be murdered by the
cops blah blah et cetera
but so often these scared people act
exactly like this woman
she's scared of the cop and yet she's
going out of her way to antagonize him
she's yelling at him insulting him
trying to
instigate a reaction she's already
gotten a break
they're about to let her leave and she's
still screaming at him
and insulting him she's afraid that
he'll
kill her and yet she taunts him
relentlessly
is that how scared people behave have
you ever been so scared of someone
that you walk up to them and say hey you
big fat dummy kiss my ass
if you're acting that way to someone
should we assume that you're scared of
that person
we're even expected to believe that the
people who resist arrest
who actually initiate violent encounters
with police
who choose of their own volition to
create
a violent situation with police
they're scared too we're supposed to
believe
they're committing a crime they're being
arrested for committing a crime
all that is totally fair they could
simply
go off to to to to to jail fight this in
the courts
but then they decide to make it violent
didn't have to be
they made it that way because they're
scared
huh and the blm rioters in the street
who throw rocks at cops taunt them cuss
them out
sometimes strip off their clothes and
dance naked in front of them
they're scared too supposedly all of
these people professing to be deathly
afraid of the police and yet acting
towards the police
in exactly the sort of way you'd act
towards someone if you weren't afraid of
them in the slightest
could it be that all this talk about
being scared is nonsense
could it be that it's nothing but
emotional blackmail
an act a charade to justify their own
despicable and indefensible behavior
yes it could be and it is in fact
nearly everything you hear from the
anti-cop left
is bogus everything
the claims they make about policing in
general are statistically false
but even the claims they make about
their own emotional states
are also false it is all false
all a every bit of it
and we should never forget that now
let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know it has been a difficult time
this last year it's always hard when
you're a business owner
to deal with all the issues that come up
but this last year especially has not
made it
any easier uh and that's why
ziprecruiter
is so important they make at least one
aspect of being a business owner a lot
easier if you're a business owner who's
hiring you probably face a lot of
challenges when it comes to finding
the right person for the job that's why
hiring can feel like you know trying to
find a needle in the haystack sure you
could post your job
online you could post it on some kind of
job board but then all you're doing is
hoping that the right person stumbles
across it which is why
forget about that you need to try
ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
walsh when you post a job on zip
recruiter it gets sent to over 100 top
job sites with one click
then zip recruiters magic technology
finds people with the right skills and
experience
for your job and actively invites them
to apply so this is a proactive solution
rather than putting something out there
into the ether of cyberspace and helping
someone stumbles across it
uh zip recruiter is going to go find
that candidate for you in fact zip
recruiter is so affected that four out
of five employers
who post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day okay so
while other companies overwhelm you with
way too many options zip recruiter finds
you what you're looking for
which is that needle in the haystack and
right now you could try zip recruiter
for free at this web address
ziprecruiter.com walsh once again
remember to go to this unique place
ziprecruiter.com
w-a-l-s-h zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
okay so uh number one here you know i
always say never apologize to the
outrage mob
here's another exhibit to enter into
consideration for that
rick santorum was uh speaking at a yaf
conference
and we're good friends with yaf over
here big big
fans and partners with yaf and he was
speaking at a conference a few days ago
um i think this was in dc i believe but
i could be wrong about that
and uh he got into some some trouble
because of what he said about
about our history this country's history
uh here are
the allegedly offensive remarks listen
if you think about
this country i don't have any other
country in the world that was settled
predominantly by people who were coming
to practice their faith
they came here because they were not
allowed to practice their particular
faith in their own country
and so they came here mostly from europe
and they set up a country
that was based on judeo-christian
principles
when i say judeo-christ the mosaic laws
ten commandments
and the teachings of jesus christ the
morale the morals and teachings of jesus
christ that's
that's what our founding documents are
based upon
it's in our dna you know if you think of
other countries like
italy and greece and china and turkey
and places like that
they've all sort of changed over time
i mean they've been they've been there
for sent for millennia
in many cases and their culture has sort
of evolved over time
but not us we came here
and created a blank slate we birthed a
nation
from nothing i mean there's nothing here
i mean yes we have native americans but
but candidly that that there isn't much
native american culture in american
culture
it it was born of the people who came
here
pursuing religious liberty to
practice their faith to live as they
ought to live
and have the freedom to do so religious
liberty
okay well yes all of that is true
no problem with any of that that's all
completely true um
it it it is true that
the european settlers built a country
that built a civilization
our civilization they built it from
scratch they built it from the ground up
they built it from a blank slate they
did
when they came here there were there was
a there were scattered collections
of warring primitive tribes
these were essentially stone not
essentially these were
for the most for the most part stone age
primitive tribes um and they they
weren't all
one big we talk about you know the
indians or native americans as if
they're one homogenous group
uh they're not and they certainly
weren't
back in those days
they were scattered across um
north america and south america and they
were
at war with each other i mean in a
constant state of war with each other in
fact
european settlers came and they built
our civilization as we know it today
all of that is true it just is now you
could
you might not like that it's true you
might prefer that people don't
acknowledge that it's true
but it is true
now uh but rick santorum got into a lot
of trouble with that with the left and
they were very upset and he was his name
was trending and
everybody was outraged and he went on
uh cnn with chris cuomo a couple nights
ago to address that
now he didn't apologize and i want to
give him credit for not apologizing
and i do sort of but but he he
he all he all but apologized he
backpedaled and he was kind of like
stammering over his words a little bit
and he was he said that he misspoke he
didn't mean to say that
which is effectively an apology you know
it's kind of he's dissembling and he's
trying to get his way out of it but he
doesn't actually say that he's sorry
so he all but apologizes which is
unfortunate you know i wish he would
have gone
on cnn and said no i don't yeah i said
what i said i meant it it's true
oh you don't like it it offends you well
you know i don't care it this is a
simple fact
i wish he would have done that but he
didn't but he also didn't
say the words i'm sorry and we know with
the left
so even if you apologize they're not
gonna be satisfied but if you don't even
do that
i mean if they're if they're upset at
you about something
and the first words out of your mouth
aren't i'm sorry
oh man they can't talk about entitlement
they can't wrap their heads around that
they
they're going to be left speechless and
so now we go to don lemon who was
the day after was talking to i think
this is the day after talking to
uh chris cuomo about that
exchange with rick santorum where he
doesn't explicitly apologize
and don lemon is he's sputtering he's
he's nearly speechless
that he can't believe he just can't
believe that rick santorum didn't
apologize
uh to the whole world and i guess you
know don lemon personally wanted an
apology to him too
so here's uh here's don lemon rendered
nearly speechless
i was serious watching the interview in
my office i cannot believe the first
words out of his mouth
weren't i'm sorry i said something
ignorant
i you know i need to learn about the
history of this country
no contrition didn't talk about
you know the suffering that native
americans have had to deal with
in this country it was i mean rick
santorum really
who did he think did he actually think
it was a good idea for him to come on
television
and try to whitewash the whitewash that
he whitewashed i mean
it was it was horrible it was horrible
and insulting and i apologize to the
viewers
who were insulted by it because i was
sitting in my office
furious because he's done it so many
times
so many times and it's just i'm sorry it
was just
it was so egregious and insulting
and everything that we talk about
about the founding of this country the
europeans did not found
found this country it was here the
native americans had this country before
the europeans came
what a drama quick calm down don you're
embarrassing yourself
this guy's so emotional i couldn't
believe it
how could he he didn't apologize i just
i can't believe it
just shut up
uh and he says uh
okay he says that rick santorum didn't
acknowledge the suffering of native
americans
so why does he have to now acknowledge
that
that's not what he was talking about
see that's the thing we can talk about
our history as a country and
as a civilization um we don't have to
run
through a list of all the sins and all
the people who are victimized before we
get to that point where we can talk
about the history
sometimes we can just talk about the
history
that the the suffering of native
americans wasn't relevant to the point
he was making
but this is what the left wants you
better not dare
in their minds say anything about
american history
without first without prefacing it with
an apology
before you before you uh express any
pride certainly
in your country's history you better
start by saying well i'm so sorry the
native americans they were they were
they suffered and
all these other minorities suffered and
everyone suffered and it was a terrible
terrible thing and everything was
horrible it's a horrible country
but also here's what i want to say
that's how you're supposed to start i'm
happy that rick santorum didn't start
that way
of course then he goes on tv and he
still backpedals and says it says that
he misspoke so he doesn't he doesn't
really get any credit for me at all
but it just goes to show there's there's
no why
backpedal at all why claim you misspoke
you didn't misspeak you said what you
meant to say and you were right you're
not gonna get any credit at all
you get zero you get zero credit
you know this is this is like a for the
left they're like
teachers where if you get one question
wrong on the test you get zero you get
no no credit at all
except the test here it's not a factual
test
the test is how much are you you know
are you lining up with
the test is all about their ideology and
how do you line up with it
and are you are you lining up with their
preconceived notions and their
ideological convictions
if you deviate from that at all
then you get zero credit so why bother
why bother you've already got
don lemon crying on camera you might as
well i wish
rick santorum had gone all the way i
wish he just sat there and laughed
and said oh people were upset about that
that's great
yeah i don't care i wish he had done
that
that would could you imagine don lemon
if merced torment said that on chris
cuomo's show
lemon would have be would be in literal
tears he'd actually be breaking down
in tears crying on camera if only
santorum had done that
and then he says that um this country
this is a a grown adult man
um allegedly
and a professional news anchor
allegedly claiming
that this country already existed before
the european settlers got here
what no it didn't
that is a historical
incoherent nonsense
this country didn't exist before the eur
oh really so
the native americans as the group
created the united states of america did
they
that's what happened we already had
everything set up the states and
everything was already uh already
established
no it there was no country
before the settlers came here
and they obviously didn't get here and
immediately start a country
this is a process of centuries
building a our civilization and then
eventually our country then eventually
founding our country
but but what is what is inarguably
true is that there was no country
when the european settlers got here the
native americans
again were talking about primitive
warring
scattered tribes
i mean the the majority of of what is
now our country was
empty space wide wide open empty space
and scattered throughout it were these
primitive warring tribes they didn't
have a country that they
they all got together and made a country
together no
there was nothing even resembling a
country
so that's nonsense so what happens you
don't apologize to the left
and uh you know basically if they're
coming after you
you have two choices and there's no
reason to go anywhere in between
and one choice is to flip them a bird
and say i don't care about your feelings
or i don't care that you're upset
i said what i said i'm not gonna
apologize you know what even if i was
wrong i won't apologize to you how do
you like them apples
but i'm not wrong so you could do that
that's my recommended path uh or if
you're not gonna do that then you might
as well go all the way
get on your knees groveling
crying begging for forgiveness
you probably still won't get it but
there's a chance
maybe anything in between
it's really pointless you you now you
you lose it's a lose-lose situation
because now like what rick santorum did
you're not getting respect from
you know the people who are on the anti
cancel culture side of things like me
okay we're not gonna respect you
because you didn't really stick to your
guns but the cancel culture folks
they're not gonna accept you either
they're still gonna try to cancel you
so what did you achieve chief nothing
all right um moving on number two here
caitlyn jenner running for governor of
california as i'm sure you've heard
provided an answer on the girls sports
issue that has gotten a lot of attention
and here is that answer hi caitlin
so there's legislation in various states
to ban biological boys
who are trans from playing girl sports
in school what's your opinion on that
inbox and
this is a question of fairness
that's why i oppose biological boys who
are trans
competing in girl sports in school it
just
isn't fair and we have to protect
girl sports but but if someone
transitions and now identifies as a girl
isn't it delegitimizing their identity
to prevent them
that was a fine answer i
i obviously agree with jenner
on that point but predictably
a lot of people on the right a lot of
conservatives are celebrating this
and say oh look at this jenner's on our
side what a powerful
advocate what a powerful advocate
against the trans agenda is caitlyn
jenner
yeah i just keep keep something in mind
here okay i want to read to you
this is a cnn article from 2018.
not all that long ago just a few years
here's uh here's what cnn had to say um
based on caitlyn jenner's own words
in 2018 reading from the article okay it
says kailyn jenner says she and
again i'm reading the cnn article this
is their language that i'm reading not
my own when it comes to the pronouns
um kayla jenner says she made a mistake
in thinking
she could work with president donald
trump to benefit the lgbtq community and
is now no longer a trump supporter
in a washington post op-ed published on
thursday by the way i wanted to read the
actual op-ed to you but it's behind a
paywall
and uh i ain't paying for that so we
gotta settle with cnn okay
in a washington post op-ed published
thursday jenner said at first she
believed she could work with trump and
republicans to change the party's stance
on lgbtq issues
jenner wrote sadly i was wrong the
reality is that the trans community is
being relentlessly attacked by this
president
she argued that trump has shown no
regard for an already marginalized and
struggling community
general believe believing that i could
work with trump in his administration to
support our community was a mistake
she pointed to a new york times uh
report that the department of health and
human services has drafted a proposal to
define gender under title
ix as solely male or female at birth
with no room for change
jenner said her hope in trump and
republicans was misplaced
and that she cannot support anyone who
was working against our community
i don't support trump i must learn from
my mistakes and move forward
okay now
you might say that the sports issue from
what i could tell based on cnn report
anyway
the sports issue was not specifically
addressed in that op-ed
but jenner was coming out forcefully in
favor of quote trans rights
and we know what that means you know
what anytime you hear trans rights and
advocating for trans rights
well it doesn't mean like trans people
should have
first amendment rights and second
amendment rights because everyone agrees
with that
those aren't trans rights those are
everyone's rights
no matter who you are so anytime you put
the qualifier in front of it
something is wrong same goes for women's
rights
you know you hear anytime you hear
someone advocate for women's rights in
modern society
um you can you know that whatever
they're about to say
is is wrong and bad because women
already have in our society
all of the same rights as men all the
same legal rights
all of them so if you're hearing about
something called women's rights well now
that means that there's additional
rights
specific qualified rights specifically
for women that they're advocating
such as for example the right to kill
their children men don't have that right
that is a
that is a right that only women have and
so these days when someone is advocating
for women's rights
that's what they're advocating for
uh because again everyone has all the
same
basic rights and protections we all do
and i wish that we could celebrate that
and be happy
and say you know we all have equal
rights in this country
um it's we've achieved it as as much as
we can hope to ever achieve something
like that we've achieved
it but no so when it comes to trans
rights
trans people have all the same basic
rights basic protections under the law
they even have the right to participate
in sports despite how the media frames
it in the media headlines
no one is advocating for bills to ban
trans people from sports
nobody i have not heard any single
person say that
all we're saying is that if you're a
biological male you play with the boys
if you're a
biological female you play with the
girls and if you happen to be trans
whatever fine you know you could be
trans you could identify however you
want
but sports is going to be determined
based on biology
that's it again trans rights
means advocating for extra additional
rights
um and that's what jenner is advocating
for in this article
that's what jenner has advocated for and
now we're supposed to believe
all of a sudden he's had a change of
heart on this
and yet still identifies as trans
himself
yeah i don't buy it for for a second i
don't buy it for a second and if you
if you actually think if you listen to
that and you believe that
jenner is now going to be an effective
fighter against an advocate against
the left's agenda on gender and
sexuality and all that then i you know
naive
does not even begin to describe you it
really doesn't
as conservatives you know we got to be
smarter than this
we need to start we need to find
effective
advocates for the conservative cause
not poor or mediocre advocates who
happen to check a few of the identity
boxes
because that's the strategy we've been
trying to use for years it doesn't work
so we'll say yeah this person isn't that
great or compelling and um
it's kind of milk toast at best but uh
you know they
they have this or that they fall into
this or that identity category and so
the left will be stumped they won't know
what to do
doesn't work the left has already the
left has already disowned
caitlyn jenner they did that years ago
really
they certainly done it now
so whatever you think whatever
conservative cause you think will be
more powerful
coming out of caitlyn jenner's mouth
you're wrong
okay you're wrong what we need are
people who are just
powerful advocates of their own accord
wherever they fall
on the you know whatever their
demographics are
powerful advocates caitlyn jenner is not
a powerful advocate
of anything least of all conservative uh
cause all right
bill gates made an announcement
yesterday here's the statement
he says after a great deal of thought
and a lot of work on our relationship we
have made the decision to end our
marriage
over the last 27 years we have raised
three incredible children and built a
foundation that works all over the world
to enable all people to lead healthy
productive lives
we continue to share belief in that
mission and we'll continue our work
together at the foundation but we no
longer believe we can grow together as a
couple in this
in this next phase of our lives we ask
for space and privacy for our family
as we begin to navigate this new life
now listen
um normally i would say
people's marriage troubles even if
they're famous none of our business
what is there to to say about it we
should we should just butt out but
bill gates has no problem imposing his
personal opinions and views on our lives
he has no problem using his position and
his wealth and his power
to impose on us he's been doing it all
throughout the pandemic
you know he had no he had no problem
advocating um
using his position to advocate for
policies that would wipe out thousands
of businesses for example there's no
problem doing that
now with vaccines he's doing the you
know he has no problem imposing himself
um certainly having an opinion about you
and i as peons
how we live and the choices that we make
and so in that spirit i have no problem
in this case having an opinion about him
in his life
i think in fact i think it's with all
due respect to him
you know he doesn't he's not one for
personal privacy clearly
uh and so out of respect for him i'm not
gonna respect his personal privacy and
what i will say
is that there is nothing more pathetic
than a couple after three decades of
marriage
now in their in their mid to late 60s
divorcing so they can move on to the
next phase of their lives so they can
grow
more as people there is nothing more
pitiful
or pathetic than that
i i will i just will never understand it
you've been through
three decades you know you're on the
last
part of your life you know you might
have several more years left you might
have a few decades left but you're like
you know you're you're this is the last
lap
if this is a mile race on an olympic
size track and uh you know four four
four laps around this is you're like the
last lap here
and you made it through the other laps
together why not
that's how you grow you know you don't
grow as a person
by by giving up this idea there's
another reason why
i have no problem commenting on this
because it's a poisonous idea that goes
far beyond the bill gates
bill gates's marriage the idea that you
can grow
as a person by by giving up on your
on your vows by breaking your promises
by being disloyal to each other that's
going to help you grow
you grow in this final lap
when maybe you're tired of each other
whatever you're going through you know
there's there's
you you there's conflicts you're not
seeing eye to eye
maybe you feel like it's been a loveless
marriage for a long time whatever the
case is
you grow by sticking with each other you
know hand in hand
and you say i know you want to quit i
want to quit we're not going to we're
going to
we're going to see this through that's
the promise we made we're gonna we're
gonna finish it we're gonna finish the
job
that's growth
um this is this is not growth at all and
now a word from one of our favorite
sponsors here on the show
rockauto.com you know rockauto.com it's
all about
making your life easier and making
things quicker too because as we get
into the warmer months
uh you know you want to spend more time
outside you want to spend more time
especially on the weekend with your
family you don't want to be wasting time
in an auto parts store
and you don't have to with rockauto.com
you've got rockauto.com
at your desk in your pocket you carried
around with you all the time
rockauto.com
always offers the lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices based on you
know if you're a professional or do it
yourself or it's going to be the same
price for everybody
same selection for everybody
rockauto.com is a family business
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years
go to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
uh and if you find it on rawickauto.com
whatever you're looking for
you're going to find it most likely on
rockauto.com and you're also going to
know that whatever the price is there
it's the best price you're going to find
anywhere
so you can stop your search amazing
selection reliably low prices all the
parts your car will ever need
at rockauto.com so go to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car
truck and as always remember to write
walsh in there how did you hear about
this box
so they know that we sent you let's move
on now to
reading the youtube comments this is
from terence says matt
wouldn't your belief in ufos disprove
your catholic convictions
uh i don't see how it does at all you
know i know
i know a lot of people think that it
does whether catholic or or whatever
you know i i know there are a lot of
christians who think that their
religion precludes them
from entertaining the idea that there
could be other
intelligent life forms uh in out there
in the physical universe
and i i just don't see that as the case
you know the this is one of the many
subjects that the bible doesn't
address the bible doesn't say anything
about the bible never says that there
are no
other intelligent life forms out there
it never says that there are
you know um that's the bible's not
interested
in that question which doesn't mean it's
not an interesting question or an
important one
um so i i think as christians
we can we can arrive at different
conclusions on it um but i don't think
that our
faith necessitates that we arrive at one
conclusion or another
and there's plenty of precedent for that
by the way among among great christian
thinkers
c.s lewis famously speculated about
intelligent life forms and he didn't
think it was out of the question at all
so all right charles says i had to mash
the the
uh thumbs up button three times for it
to register and i'm just feeding the
algorithm
well i guess that's why is why they say
have to smash it i never knew like why
do you have
all the youtube people they say you have
to smash the like button
i guess this is why in order to really
with force to make sure that it
registers
uh another comment says your argument
for pit bulls
sounds similar to an argument for gun
owners you could literally swap the two
i don't understand this here's another
thing i don't understand
that is the argument that i was
addressing yesterday i was explaining
the difference
between gun rights and your pitbull
rights
and so what you're doing is you're
simply you're not you're not disputing
my argument
you're just restating the argument that
i was attempting to debunk
you're not adding any additional
arguments or making any point you're
restating it
this is how arguments go on the internet
all the time
somebody makes a statement you know i
say oh
uh i just agree with that statement for
xyz reason
and then you get a whole bunch of
comments from people who are no i don't
think so and then they
they just restate the statement
do you think that's how an argument goes
we keep shouting assertions at each
other back and forth whoever stops
talking first loses is that the way you
think this goes
banned from the show but thanks for the
comment and for listening
um let's see mrs hancock says in 2019
33 of 46 fatal dog attacks were
committed by pit bulls
well you know that's not enough to
convince people there's a problem though
i guess
maybe it's got to be 46 of 46.
um sasha says hey matt you know i love
you i don't have to remind you of that
but it's my last day at work from for
home depot been there for two years and
i'm joining a different company
i just need to get your approval for
playing your show on the pa system
for my last day make some leftist ears
bleed of truth
does this sound too rash well
i cannot tell you to do that
i also will not tell you to not do that
that's all i'll say um
and uh finally says matt i was really
waiting for you to be edgy and include
the fifth
uh fifth option when it comes to where
the ufos are coming from and i think
most plausible option
but it's actually demons posing as
aliens
i mean the mass deception would be so
easy to pass off once the rapture
happens why is a christian
could you see space creatures as more
plausible than satan and his fallen
angels which we know are in fact real
this is another one i don't i guess
that's the theme of the show today i
don't understand i don't understand this
one either i
uh why would we
why would satan and the devils be flying
around
in crafts in the sky picked up on radar
just
darting around and then they're gone
like i
i don't understand that theory i don't i
don't get where that's
coming from why why would we assume that
um i hear that a lot i hear that a lot
as a speculation
and i admit you know we could put that
on the list of possibilities
really the list of possibilities is is
there are probably hundreds of items on
the list
some more probable than others i would
put that on the less probable
end of the spectrum just because i don't
know
i certainly never imagined angels flying
around an actual
aircraft um i wouldn't think they would
need that so
that's my problem with that i'm sure you
guys have noticed that the daily wire
has been growing like crazy you know not
only did we
move the entire company across the
country but we also released our first
feature film we struck up a movie deal
with
gina carano we started the new talk show
hosted by candace owens and this is all
in the first
six months uh at least in the last six
months ever since we got to nashville so
just imagine
what else is going to happen what the
future has in store
for us and you as an audience we've been
moving at light speed over here and so i
am so excited for the future of the
company and we're grateful for
all of you for supporting the company
but we want to make sure that we
continue to include
you and our future plans so every day on
my show i talk about a lot of different
sponsors a lot of great sponsors and
products and services from our sponsors
that i love and use but we want to get
to know you better so we can choose our
sponsors with you in mind so please go
to dailywire.com
walsh and fill out my audience survey to
tell us a little bit more about yourself
and the good news is
you should just do it because it's the
right thing to do and i'm asking you to
but if that's not good enough and it
probably isn't you also
uh can enter to win a 1 000 gift card if
you go again to dailywire.comwalsh
and go there now fill that out also if
you haven't checked out candace yet
tonight's the night to do it not only is
it premiering live
for free but her special guest is none
other than donald trump
they discuss everything from big tech
censorship to what trump's future might
hold
so it's not a conversation you're going
to want to miss candace is free during
the premiere but will only be available
to members after it
ends so catch it live tonight at 9 pm
eastern a pm central only on
dailywire.com
if you still haven't subscribed this is
the last week to get 25
off with code candace before the deal
ends on may 6. so again
uh last chance go to dailywire.com
subscribe and use code candace for 25
off now let's get to our daily
cancellation
and yet another old disney film finds
itself in the chopping block this time
it's snow white in the seven dwarfs
the path to cancellation begins with the
recent reopening of disneyland i don't
have to reiterate my general view of
theme parks especially ones owned and
operated by disney i'll only say that if
disney world is hell on earth which it
is i can only imagine what disneyland
must be like
disneyland is the knockoff version of
hell it somehow manages to be a
downgrade from hell it's like going from
a comfort into a motel 6
or from a mcdonald's to a burger king
but that's not the point here the point
is that the website
sf gate owned by the san francisco san
francisco chronicle
published a review of the new disneyland
experience
it was mostly positive but it did
include this bit about the snow white
ride
it said quote the new grand finale of
snow white's enchanted wish
is the moment when the prince finds snow
white asleep under the evil queen's
spell and gives her true love's kiss
to release her from the enchantment a
kiss he gives to her without her consent
while she's asleep
which cannot possibly be true love if
only one person knows it's happening
haven't we already agreed that consent
in early disney movies is a major issue
that teaching kids that kissing when it
hasn't been established if both parties
are willing to engage is not okay
it's hard to understand why the
disneyland of 2021 would choose to add a
scene with
such old-fashioned ideas of what a man
is allowed to do to a woman
especially when the company's current
emphasis on removing problematic scenes
from rides like
jungle cruise and splash mountain why
not reimagine an ending in keeping with
the spirit of the movie
and snow white's place in the disney
canon but that avoids this problem
yes and what a problem it is lots of
bigoted right-wingers have been making
fun of this passage in the article but i
don't see what's so funny they raised a
good point snow white
was actually not only sleeping but it
was believed that she was dead right
it's been a while since i've seen the
movie but she was she was dead i mean
they thought she was dead
the dwarves put her in a coffin until
the prince shows up and begins to
sexually assault a woman that he
believes to be dead this is
normalization of necrophilia
as well as rape culture and what about
those dwarves
we're just going to leave aside the fact
that they attempted no form of
resuscitation
no first aid of any kind before deciding
to put her in a coffin and leave her for
dead
well i mean wasn't she if she was just
sleeping she was breathing
they even tried splashing some cold
water in her face or something
put her in a car in a glass coffin that
was exactly the right size
i might add did they just have that
lying around
they invite a woman into the house and
they have a coffin her size
waiting outside for her these troubling
questions go unanswered
that's all to say nothing of the fact
that none of the dwarves to my knowledge
were voiced by actual doors
just as a magic mirror was not voiced by
an actual magic mirror or even a regular
mirror
representation matters and snow white
gets it wrong on that front time and
time again
and what about snow white herself now
not to victim blame
but she's in her kitchen one day when a
random creepy old hag
shows up at the window giggling
maniacally
and pushing a piece of fruit into her
face and telling her to take a bite
and she does can you imagine someone
knocking on your door
and they got an evil smirk and they say
hey i got an apple for you
why don't you take a bite and you say
well gee i am kind of hungry
chomp what kind of food safety message
does that send to our kids
suffice it to say there's plenty of
reasons to cancel snow white and not
just her let's get it all over with why
trickle the cancellations out let's do
them all at once
why hasn't aladdin been cancelled yet
yeah they remade it and injected some
you know additional wokeness into the
screenplay
but the whole premise of the movie is
one that normalizes and romanticizes
forced labor
the genie is a slave in bondage
imprisoned in a tiny cell
and has to sing and dance and perform
tricks in order to win his freedom
it's no wonder there are so many white
supremacists in this country when
they've grown up on
movies that normalize the enslavement of
people of color specifically the color
blue in this case but still
also the lion king it celebrates
autocracy through the problematic
benevolent dictator trope embodied by
mufasa
meanwhile the marginalized hyenas are
cast out into the dark lands
and when scarred the marxist
revolutionary leads the hyenas in a
class
uprising it's cast by the film as a
nightmarish event
the audience is meant to cheer when the
privileged son simba returns from his
sabbatical to claim the throne
kills the revolutionaries throws them
into a fire
the whole thing is highly offensive and
problematic
what about pinocchio the film ruthlessly
reinforces the gender binary
by by revolving around pinocchio's
desire to be
a quote real boy now a simple change
here would have turned it from a
bigoted hate fest into a true artistic
triumph
pinocchio would have needed only to
transition into rather than a real boy
a girl or a trisexual polygamist
or even just simply a pansexual lesbian
non-binary
semi-female genderqueer starbucks
barista
why not that but there's no salvaging it
now pinocchio should be canceled
beauty and the beast needs to face
consequences the one good thing about
that movie is that it has a very
progressive
attitude towards sex bell enters into a
romantic
and consensual for the most part i mean
she was imprisoned by the guy
so yeah but aside from that
a romantic and consensual bestiality
relationship with the beast and that's
you know very progressive very
enlightened
uh surely should that should be
applauded but the rest of it is
profoundly objectionable
consider the teapot character a woman
uh is made into a literal object
it is the most blatant case of
objectification ever put to film
and that's nothing compared to the to
the other character the feather duster
if you can believe it the movie depicts
not only a woman turned into an
object but the object is an actual
feather duster
now any old misogynist will say that
women should do the cleaning but it
takes misogyny on steroids
to suggest that women should actually be
the cleaning supplies
my god cancel beauty and the beast
cancel them all you know we need to move
past movies as a society
if you want to be entertained just stare
at a blank tv screen that's what i do
create your own movies in your head last
night i sat for three hours and i stared
at my screen and i imagined that i was
watching
an action film about a black disabled
lesbian trans woman
beating up oil executives and nra
lobbyists
hollywood thinks it's woke but it isn't
work enough to make that movie yet
maybe it never will be and so for now
disney is canceled all disney movies are
canceled
all other movies are cancelled it's all
canceled
and that will do it for us today thanks
for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by mika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. house
republican
leader liz chaney sounds like and is a
big lib
don lemon denies that europeans founded
america and catholic bishops get tough
on pro-abortion politicians check it out
on the michael knoll show